it happened okay what type of
arrangement is this
okay that bishop in the corner does not
have to move and okay ideal placement
queen and Bishop needing to move in
order to King side castle I like c5 as a
move just so I could get knight c6 in
and what else let me see a non mover now
we're having might be a non mover
okay that is where we're at okay now
what um c 5 c 5 i think is a good start
so I'm gonna go with that nothing is
unprotected from this initial position
except actually this square ooh so that
should actually have my attention
because maybe night getting here real
quick is good oh oh oh that I should
have maybe played this right away hmm
let's see do this two reasons defend the
pond and also stop maybe a night from
getting to this square where would I see
seven and what else what else here if
Knight c3 i think i might be needing to
do this okay now let's hit again mmm i
do this now dual purpose move one and
this is what I'll look to do oh very
often and that is when I'm making pawn
moves have them serve more than one
purpose defense and my bishop can see I
think I take now and this position is
opening up quickly and I am not in a
position to be defending against all
these threats I think this is the
biggest one right now how do I deal with
the night coming here
oh this is pretty scary I don't want the
night to get to this square this is like
a hedgehog right here but of course it's
a different setup isn't it dark square
Bishop out and then maybe Queen out here
really quick
oh let's see okay I could throw in a
check and I'm going to do that if the
pond blocks then I could say the bishop
isn't going to be playing any time soon
or the night or I'm not playing any time
soon but really okay these guys won't be
making use of the C 3 square um what
else ok I think I just get my queen here
I want to be able to Castle soon and my
queen is ready to come out I think
things are ok right now I was very
worried ok let's take here and I'm
actually getting this pond now not just
to take upon but I want to be able to
castle this is hit but there's nothing
threatened its defended already so now I
could finally get these guys out 96 and
we'll actually maybe even be five keep
this night away my queen does have
places to retreat let's get that night
out of here knight c6 coming up but
before that let me get this in I think I
want to keep a night on this square and
I guess there's some defensive duty it
might have over here on g6 but not
really seeing any attack just develop
but wait this night is could be pinned
right now Queen here the Knights pinned
the Queen esthe pressure on this pond
Queen has to block here or the night has
to retreat or the bishop has to retreat
it's a usually a very difficult position
if you're in a pin but if you're in a
pin and the piece is unprotected you
have fewer choices you should be trying
to break the pin and defend the piece
but right now the pit both both
requirements aren't really being met
right now you follow that if you and
find yourself in a position
where your piece is pinned and
unprotected you should be looking to do
two things break the pin and protect it
in this case it's being protected but
not broken the king is still in a pin
here so how Kyle else can I pile up on
this night is what I'm asking myself I'm
not seeing a way to do that but I'm
getting in a position to do just that
with a rook to f8 move neither Bishop
I'm not sure which one is better i'm
gonna go with the bishop rook c8 and
then there's a night move maybe or a
bishop move and then i'm on the night
okay so rook c8 or even d5 why not d 5
this is it's really like a Sicilian
still isn't it so and now i look to open
the position up quickly my queen has a
lot of lateral movement right now she
cannot be dislodged from this square
this is a problem I wonder if there was
something earlier when I was having to
make all these different pond modes was
their way to break up in the position in
a different way that duck that
definitely got really scary right there
when I was making these a a and B pawn
moves so this is this is busted as far
as I could tell this is this is big
trouble right here double check coming
up let me take here first if the Queen
recaptures I take here with check and
then pick the night off I'm actually
considering this I know this is even
better than capturing if pond takes I
take with the night hitting the Queen
and the night and threatening discovered
attacks against the king discovered
checks what else
okay now this is just ending up in a
fork that was the other threat there are
too many different things I could be
threatening to do recaptured with the
night with the fork pushing with the
fork capturing with the discovered check
it's a lot of different moves to be
meeting with just a single pond really
having all those possibilities so let me
just meet this threat I'm on the night
and this threat is still maintained what
else okay just take the night i'm on c2
if this rook wasn't here Abby rook takes
rook me well even actually what I was
actually trying to picture there is if
the king was on fa and this rook was off
the board that would still be me okay so
let me just take here and then take on
c2 and get this pawn my night would love
to be on that square let's take here
with check their down on time let's go
back quickly and see where there is
maybe some improvement so right here I
should have really given consideration
to going after your sepan and I think
you could be doing that to me too like
right now instead of the pond know maybe
night here I think I really have to
start to scramble all of a sudden 93
there's both d5 and b5 available for
your night I think I might be in some
trouble with just a column developing
move d 5 or b-five Knight c3 if i stop
night d5 there's night b5 and i think
i'm having to go to the edge night a 6
that's really uncomfortable to do that
though because your night on b5 can't be
kicked away if my night is on a 6 that
means i can't push my pawn to a6 and
kick them away so look into that
identifying first the weak points in the
96
arrangement and then look to maybe
pinpoint it could be very uncomfortable
to be defending against that sort of
stuff was there something a little bit
later that seemed right actually to just
play d4 and open a position maybe maybe
there's something else here instead of
that beep on push maybe just go with
your bishop out your clean out and
Castle maybe look to get in c4 just like
it's a like Roxy bind on the d5 square
because that's the kind of structure we
have it's like a Sicilian structure see
four nights ii 3v3 later I don't know if
allowing me to get this check in you
know after you play b3 and weak in these
dark skies I don't know if it's a good
idea to allow this Bishop check yeah I'm
definitely better at this point I'm
ready to castle and I'm up material so i
think the early suggestion again that
Knight c3 move very interesting to get
to that c7 square with that arrangement